український бойовий танк оплота викликано
дим знай кролицю світлі для курей
оборонпрому ціни і довжини править при
хитай танк вона ставиться tkip склади але
switch змінений комплектуючих четвірок
це емоція балон не могла його
але російської агресії все прибрано
техніку противника лист на вихід обрядів
техніку апарату з москвою на моє право
на і створено каталог імпортозаміщення
окей на рукави і на 10000 на яких
позицій до заміщення c6 nike mag
орніш із Російської Федерації заглушена
фактично вся промисловість України ми
наказуємо меморандуми з областями та
вже прогрес на 15 областей і знову
підписав і таки меморандуми заданим
укроборонпром вже замістив і 35 сотки в
російську імпорту технічно просити за
крему з країни ми членами там баєри
iv один з ти хто проти ти
з Україною у мій живе початку бойових
дій на донбасі
день представляємо ріканського барона
компанію тикстон systems ми про термос
бахати макро і нами можна сказати ще
робота за чекай ваш до
з чиновником алсу був у алли тут у
україні в собі лише манш добрі ми
підписали контракти у міноборони кажуть
він зображує на комплімент збоку
американської компанії приватне
публічні партнерства у сфері оборони
дофіна початкова море поза в Україні їжу
дають у сувої седмін закладіть вигляд
активності самих інвесторів створювали
чому харчування нас
харчування щоб він його не об'їдалася
і я ікла компанії так і на вали для
компанії та висувала свою позицію
якось викладено оборону реформа в Україні
на відьміну менше експерти виїжджають
будеш менше завзятий у team це ви
заходьте традиційні проблеми
бюрократію чи корупцію за слова миша
американського посла джаффе поета вина
проти корупції c часті новини проти
кремля